MATT SINGER: How's
everybody doing?
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
MATT SINGER: Did you guys
just watch the movie?
Yes?
You guys just watched
the movie, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MATT SINGER: So you know
who these people are, right?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Not me.
MATT SINGER: We've
got David Gordon
Green, writer-director
right here.
All right.
Paul Rudd and Emile Hirsch.
My name's Matt Singer.
I work for a website
called "The Dissolve."
And thanks for having me.
Thanks for having us.
How you guys doing?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Fantastic.
PAUL RUDD: Good.
MATT SINGER: You have something
you want to address, I know.
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah.
MATT SINGER: You want to get
it off your chest right now?
EMILE HIRSCH: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, now that I'm at Google.
So if you type in
my name on Google,
the Google profile
says I'm 5' 5".
That's not true.
I'm 5' 7 and 3/4".
When you're 5' 7 and 3/4",
5' 5" sounds fucked up.
No offense to anybody who may
be 5' 5" or close to 5' 5".
MATT SINGER: It's fine
if that's who you are.
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah,
but when you're
not that-- It's not a big deal.
I just figured I'm in
the offices of Google.
MATT SINGER: Can we get this
taken care of right now?
Anyone?
EMILE HIRSCH: I'm just
throwing that out there.
MATT SINGER: Maybe afterwards
someone can take care of that.
All right.
We threw it out there.
I'm sure by the time this
is over, we'll go on Google
and it'll be right.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT SINGER: Maybe?
They're laughing like it's
not, but I was serious.
EMILE HIRSCH: I'm
going to be 5' 1".
They're like, ask
us again, bitch.
See what happens.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: [INAUDIBLE].
MATT SINGER: 5' 5"
was close enough.
PAUL RUDD: 4' 10".
MATT SINGER: While
they're fixing that,
let's talk about the movie.
I walked in to the movie not
knowing much more about it
other than you guys.
And then I was really
surprised to find out
that it was a remake
of another movie.
I had no idea.
And it didn't feel
like one to me.
So maybe you can talk about
the origins of the project.
Reading a little
more about it, it
seemed like it wasn't
like you saw the movie
and wanted to make that.
There's kind of an interesting,
unusual process there.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: It's a
little bit backward, yes.
I was directed to go to this
state park in Bastrop, Texas.
I live in Austin.
This is about an hour
outside of Austin.
And a friend of
mine was telling me
how interesting this
particular state
park was after this wild
fire has swept through.
And he said, you should go
to check this place out.
It's really cinematic
and interesting.
And you should
make a movie there.
So I went to the park
and checked it out
and thought, oh, this
is really awesome.
I should make a movie here.
But what was beautiful about it
is also the devastation of it.
And it was this apocalyptic,
monochromatic forest.
And it went on for
25 square miles.
I mean, it was just an enormous,
very catastrophic wildfire.
People lost their homes.
A number of people,
actually filmmaker
Richard Linklater, some of his
property was affected by it,
and some people that I knew.
And so it was
interesting walking
through this place
thinking about it
as a very haunted
backdrop location.
I thought this would
make a great place
to make a movie that had
that kind of strange beauty,
sad thing going on in it.
I need to come up with
a very simple story,
something cool that
I can do really
quickly before the forest turns
green again in the summertime.
And then, coincidentally,
I was telling
a friend of mine
that lives up here,
a production designer up
here, and I was telling him
this beautiful place I found.
And I said, I need a
really stripped down,
simple narrative that then
I can get great actors
and make a great
character piece.
And he said, well, I've heard
about this Icelandic film
about two guys painting
stripes on the road.
Why don't you just
remake that movie?
I asked him if it's any good.
And he said he hadn't seen
it, but it sounded cool.
MATT SINGER: Who cares?
You're going to remake it.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Exactly.
So that's what I thought.
I hunted it down.
I said, OK, I can't wait
to remake this movie that I
haven't seen or no one
I know has seen yet.
And I started watching it.
And I was like, no,
this is really good.
And I really responded
to the movie.
And I sent it to Paul.
And he liked it.
And we said, what the hell.
Let's try to get the rights
and do something with this,
and use it as a great blueprint.
Some of the dialogue is taken
precisely from the movie.
A few shots are even taken
directly from the movie.
And then we tried
to personalize it.
And each of us put
our fingerprint on it.
And elements like the
woman that Paul's character
Alvin encounters in
the burned down home
wasn't in the screenplay,
but it was an illustration
of the opportunity of making
a movie like this where
you can just open it up to that.
That was Joyce.
And that was her home.
And that was her story looking
for her pilot's licence.
And just taking advantage of the
beautiful, sad oddity, funny,
strangeness of this environment
became a great journey
for all of us.
And once we got Paul
and Emile on board,
it really just became its own
very special, very personal
project.
MATT SINGER: What were you guys
attracted to in the material
that you wanted to
be a part of it?
PAUL RUDD: Well, at first for
me, it was working with David.
David and I have known
each other for a long time.
And I've always wanted
to work with him.
And I think he's great.
Emile wasn't on board.
This was when Emile
wasn't attached
to be in it or anything.
Because when I first heard
about it, Dave was like, hey,
man, why don't we get some
cameras and go out in the--
And he didn't even have to
tell me what it was about.
But then he said, there's
this Icelandic movie
about two guys that paint
the lines on a road.
And, uh, that sounds awesome.
Like I like that.
That sounds super.
MATT SINGER: Do I get
to paint the lines?
PAUL RUDD: And it
was such a treat
to actually get to
paint the lines.
But I just thought,
oh, this would
be, one, a cool experience
to work with David.
And then I'd never met Emile.
And then when Emile came on,
I was excited about that.
But ultimately the
idea of doing something
that was purely artistic,
that it was never about,
oh, this will get picked up.
We didn't even know if it would
be in theaters or anything
like that.
But it was just a
really fun exercise
to get back in
touch with what it
is that we love about doing
this in the first place.
MATT SINGER: How about yourself?
Same thing?
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah, I mean,
I don't think that I really
even realized that we were
making a movie for most of it
because the script
was only 65 pages.
And it was only a 16-day shoot.
And every time I
would ask David--
we'd be shooting a
scene and I'd be like,
so is this going to be a movie?
And he'd be like, I don't know.
And I'd be like, well, is it
going to be shown in theaters?
Or what's it going to be like?
And he's like, this is going
to be very weird, let me just
tell you.
And I was like, OK.
And he goes, yeah.
And I was like, well, how's
it going to be distributed?
He's like, I don't know.
He's like, maybe we'll just show
it to our friends and family
over drinks and dinner.
MATT SINGER: That's got to
fill you with confidence.
EMILE HIRSCH: And
I was like, OK.
I mean, I thought
it could be a movie.
But I didn't really
know it was a movie.
And David was very
guarding about-- he never
actually said, oh, yeah,
this will be a movie that's
going to come out or
anything like that.
PAUL RUDD: We went to
the screening last night.
And really, he's
like, oh, my God.
It's a movie.
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah.
PAUL RUDD: There it is.
MATT SINGER: Does that give
you some freedom, though?
Because it seems
pretty relaxed, seems
like there's very
little pressure.
It's not like, we have to make
this and get it in theaters
and you know, it seems--
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah, I mean,
when we were shooting,
there was no press
about the movie.
It was like we basically shot
it in secret to David's design,
right?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Yes.
PAUL RUDD: There's
always pressure
because there's
other people around.
And there's a crew around.
There's a guy that's
holding a mic.
And there's somebody
that's filming it.
And there's somebody that's
setting up cones and doing
all sorts of set design.
And David's there directing.
So it's like there's always
pressure because, I mean,
acting is just stupid
and embarrassing anyway.
Just by design, it is.
EMILE HIRSCH: I think it's
more embarrassing to be
the boom guy holding it.
There's no non-awkward
way to do that.
PAUL RUDD: When you're
doing it in front of people,
it's like, yeah.
That's true.
MATT SINGER: I like when
the guy cocks it on his hip.
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah,
he thinks he's so cool
MATT SINGER: He thinks
he's really cool.
Yeah.
PAUL RUDD: No, I don't think
it's he thinks he's cool.
I think he's smart because
it's so hard to do.
Have you ever tried to do it?
It sucks.
It's terrible.
A lot of times, I've worked on
things and the takes go long.
Like sometimes, we'll just
say, let's just play around.
And we'll improvise.
We'll see where it's going.
And that's so fun
to do as an actor.
And it's terrible as a boom guy.
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah, he's
checking into the ER
the next day.
PAUL RUDD: Literally,
like, we're not
designed to just stand like that
the whole time for 20 minutes.
And I can't even do it for two.
So thank you, boom
guys out there.
MATT SINGER: Big
ups to the boom guys
PAUL RUDD: Yeah.
MATT SINGER: There are a
couple of really great scenes
that I wanted to talk about.
You mentioned one
already, that scene
where you're walking
through that house that's
been sort of destroyed
and you find this woman.
What an amazing scene.
And could you just walk through?
You said it wasn't
in the script.
It wasn't in the
original movie, right?
How did you find that?
You just found the location?
Did you find her?
How did it work?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Well we
were looking for locations--
it evolved quite a bit,
the movie, I'd say.
In the script,
there was a sequence
where Paul's character
in his lost weekend when
Emile's character goes off to
the city, his character, one
of the sequences was going to
be this funny sequence of him
going into a burned down
home and pantomiming
his way through it and talking
to someone who wasn't there
and then having ghost
sex with his wife.
And it was going
to be hilarious.
And when we're
looking for locations
for this funny scene--
MATT SINGER: I just
like watching his face
while you describe it.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: I just
thought it would be a funny,
invisible person's-- I don't
know-- provocative scene.
We got into the
process of looking
for this location for
the ghost sex scene.
And then my producer Craig
Zobel and our assistant director
Atilla were out looking
about for locations.
And they found Joyce looking
through the ashes of her home.
And they started talking to
her about potentially using
her house as a
location and then got
into the conversation of her
and her particular situation
of losing everything
in her home.
And what an amazingly
interesting woman Joyce was.
And after they had
spoken with her,
they called me and
said, listen, we
found a location that's great.
But more importantly, we found
a woman that's incredible
and somehow needs to be
integrated into this project.
So sure enough, we went
out and I don't think
she was aware, kind
of like Emile, she--
MATT SINGER: Did not
know it was a movie.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: --wasn't
sure that this was a movie.
But so Paul directed that scene.
And we went in there
very discreetly
with a cameraman and a
sound guy, our boom guy.
And Paul just talked her
through her situation.
None of that was scripted.
It was all just things that were
regurgitating the story that
had been told to our
friends previously.
And it was such a beautiful
moment just being there on set
and watching Paul's
interaction with her.
I mean, I just got chills.
Again, there's things that
she said that made me laugh.
And things that were
just really upsetting.
And the truth is, every
crack in her voice
is her holding back tears
because she lost everything
that was meaningful
to her in her life.
And she says things
like, I feel like I'm
looking through my own ashes.
And some really powerful,
gripping things that were said.
For me, personally, and I think
for Paul as well, and all four
of us that were on set
that day, it really
changed the tone
and the approach
to the rest of the film.
That funny pantomime
scene ended up
being a heartbroken scene of
Paul sitting in a chair rocking
back and forth lonely in the
rain, and very much simplified
and drained of comedy.
And the rest of the film,
too, although I think
has great laughter and
great of moments of humor.
And these guys really
did a great job
in my opinion of
balancing the comedy
and the drama of the film.
But our project became
much more emotional
after that interaction
with Joyce.
And I have to say,
having a movie that
has such a low profile
and is under the radar
and made in secret
means that we don't
have this expectation of people.
There's probably a
few die-hard fans
of the Icelandic
film "Either Way."
And a few of those guys would
be shocked and horrified
that anybody dare sabotage
their beloved film.
But here we could just
make our own thing
and make some
discoveries and take
advantage of those
opportunities.
MATT SINGER: What was that
scene like for you, Paul?
I mean, watching you talk to
her is so fascinating, too.
PAUL RUDD: It was a really
emotional experience.
And it was for her, clearly.
And we were there for a while,
I mean, obviously longer
than what you see in the film.
But to have somebody just
give you a tour of their house
that is rubble and see all the
emotion played on her face,
I was nervous that I
might say the wrong thing,
I think, through some of it.
And I actually felt
very attached to her
after we finished
shooting it because she
was so vulnerable and
so open and so fragile.
It was kind of impossible
to not get caught up in it.
MATT SINGER: Has
she seen the movie?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Yeah, she
saw it at South by Southwest.
It was really interesting.
She brought her best friend.
She called her best
friend at 11:00.
It was going to show at 4:00
in Austin this last March.
And it was going
to show at 4:00.
And she called her friend of
11:00 and says, I'm in a movie.
Do you want to come see it?
She's like, what do you
mean you're in a movie?
She's like, yep.
And then she shows
up, and her friend's
like, she didn't ever tell
me that this had happened.
And then she shows
up in a movie.
And her friend was very much a
fan of Paul and Emile's work.
She's like, why did I not
know my best friend was just
in a move with these guys?
Never happened to cross
her mind to tell me.
I think that's really funny.
But she was really
proud of the movie
and really seemed very sincere
in saying that it was a turning
point in her processing
of that event.
And just having somebody there
to listen that cared, I think,
seems like a very
meaningful thing for her.
And we had a benefit
screening last week
for the fire
department out there.
And it's really interesting
seeing the various audiences
that we've exposed to the film.
And for them, it's this hard
core, mystical dramatic film
about overcoming
this circumstance.
And other audiences, you'll
see it gets huge laughs.
And other audiences find it
very meditative and lyrical.
And others are grabbing on to
the heartbreak element of it.
And others just think
it's a boring movie
with A kick-ass soundtrack.
MATT SINGER: Well, it does have.
That, I think, is
indisputable, for sure.
We mentioned already
the painting,
the lines on the road.
This job that you guys are
doing out there, I mean,
would it really be
two guys by themselves
with one little thing?
Or is there some poetic license?
Is that from the remake-- or the
original movie, I should say?
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
In the original movie,
it was like a dude with
a roller on a brush.
So it was even more hardcore.
These guys at least
had some mechanics.
PAUL RUDD: We had
an actual machine.
MATT SINGER: Truck, at least.
PAUL RUDD: A step up.
MATT SINGER: And you got
to paint lines on the road.
Are they still there now?
Or did they immediately
get replaced?
PAUL RUDD: I think, no,
it was a special paint.
PAUL RUDD: Yeah, we had to
hose it down afterwards.
Yeah, they didn't want
our weird art project
on the middle of
their park road.
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah, because
some of those roads,
it was like if you
divided it into two lanes,
someone would drive
off the road because it
wasn't that big of a road.
PAUL RUDD: We're
painting bike lanes.
EMILE HIRSCH: I was like--
MATT SINGER: That could have
been in the movie at the end.
You go, wait a second.
Maybe there's a huge--
PAUL RUDD: What are
these cyclists going
to do without the--
EMILE HIRSCH: A truck
driver just goes off the--
MATT SINGER: This
could definitely
be me reading a little
too much into the movie.
And if it is, shoot me down.
But I'm wondering how much
of the making of this movie
is about the making
of this movie?
You guys made bigger
movies, little movies.
And you've made a
bunch of big ones.
And now you're making
a small one again.
And the movie is
about going out alone,
how you described the
process a little bit,
getting a small crew and getting
back in touch with stuff.
I'm just wondering if
you looked at it that way
at all, whether you
were sort of commenting
on your own experience.
It's based on another movie,
but to me watching it,
I could sort of see an
autobiographical element to it.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Well, I think
a lot of that is unintentional.
MATT SINGER: Fine.
I made it all up.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: But
it's not far from true.
After making the last few
projects I'd worked on
were of substantial size,
budget, and expectation,
I think stripping it all
away and stepping out
into the wilderness
much like Alvin does
is something that is a
part of my personality.
And I have a place in Colorado
I disappear to as much
as I can and try to keep
my head screwed on straight
when it gets a little wobbly.
And this project was doing a
professional version of that,
being able to strip away
so much of the paperwork
and politics of movie-making and
just the nuances of performance
were essential to this.
And it really was just the
Walden Pond of movie-making.
MATT SINGER: The
other scene that I
wanted to ask you guys about
is, I would describe it as,
the bad connection scene,
which I loved as well.
I mean, I could be
wrong again, but I'm
guessing that was not scripted.
PAUL RUDD: I don't
think that was, was it?
Yeah, it was fun to do.
And I think we knew
there was going
to be some kind of build up
and some kind of letting loose
that these characters
had to have.
And it was probably going
to be alcohol infused.
Bad connection, I
think came from--
MATT SINGER: Just
the way you said it.
I'm sorry.
EMILE HIRSCH: All
that good stuff
you said about boom guys--
DAVID GORDON GREEN: You
guys don't remember the--
EMILE HIRSCH: --makes you
sound like a huge hypocrite.
Because you remember?
It was our sound guy that we
named it after, Bad Connection.
PAUL RUDD: That was what
we called the sound guy.
It was his nickname,
Bad Connection.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: It's true.
PAUL RUDD: So we sang it.
We made a song about him.
We just called it
"Bad Connection."
EMILE HIRSCH: We sound
like hypocrites now.
PAUL RUDD: We just
sound like dicks.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Here's the novelty.
So this is what's
going to inspire
you to watch the movie again.
At the very beginning, the
song that Emile's character
puts in the tape
player when he gets
tired of listening to
the language tapes.
After we'd filmed
the movie, which
is improvised by these guys but
based on a little piece of tape
marking on the sound
pack of the boom operator
that said "bad
connection" because he
was referring to the
cable connection.
And then they
improvise the song.
And we loved it in
the editing room.
We just had so much
fun putting it together
that we had an
artist write a song
as if these guys were
riffing off the song
and just didn't
know it very well.
And so when you watch
it again, you'll
notice the song that
plays like an '80s rock
version of "Bad Connection."
PAUL RUDD: "Bad Connection."
MATT SINGER: That's like
immortalized in song.
PAUL RUDD: That's like the
most fun part of making movies.
You get to really go deep into
something absolutely stupid.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
And that no one
would recognize unless they
watch the movie 16 times.
MATT SINGER: Well, that's
what I was going to ask.
Has anyone noticed it
without you telling them?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Never.
MATT SINGER: Oh, it
will definitely happen.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
It will never happen.
MATT SINGER: We'll get to
some audience questions
maybe in a minute or two.
So if you have some
questions, start
percolating them right now.
The other member of the cast
is that the truck driver
is fabulous as well.
But he's an actor, not
someone you found, right?
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Lance LeGault?
MATT SINGER: He was cast.
Lance, yeah.
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Yeah,
you know, Lance is amazing.
I met him, I was doing
a Dodge commercial
in Tehachapi, California.
And there was a
background actor.
He was talking trash.
I was trying to figure
out the new fleet of Dodge
cars were going to
blaze through this town.
And then there's this guy
just like loud as hell over
in the corner.
I look over, and he threw
a lawn chair at a kid.
It's like, who is this guy?
And then I looked at him.
I was keeping an
eye on him, just
making sure he
didn't go berserk.
And I said, he looks
really familiar.
And then I started
talking to him
and realized I
did recognize him.
He was in some "A-Team" episodes
and a bad guy on some "Magnum,
P.I."
And he was in
"Stripes" for a minute.
And really interestingly,
he played with Elvis
for 15 years, that
singer Elvis Presley,
and traveled the
world with Elvis
and was in a bunch
of his movies.
And it's just this
larger-than-life personality.
And that was right when we were
putting the movie together.
So I thought it would be cool
to bring Lance out and play
the old cantankerous
truck driver, which
isn't far from
who he really was.
And I liked him
mainly because I knew
Emile would be terrified of him.
EMILE HIRSCH: Oh, yeah.
MATT SINGER: I was going to
say, your scenes with him
are so fun to watch
you in those scenes.
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah, I know.
I mean, I never knew what
he was going to say next.
I mean, I remember one day I was
sitting with him and his wife.
And he had his oxygen
tank on the other side.
And he had his oxygen on.
And I was asking him a question
about girls or something
like this.
And he was like, let me tell
you something about girls.
In the 1960s, I was with Elvis.
And I played bass in Vegas.
And I used it knock off two or
three pieces of pussy a day.
And he was eating
peanuts at the time.
And the peanuts were
hitting me in the face.
And I would look at him
and then just look over
to his wife to make sure she's
not twisting the oxygen tank.
Sorry, Paul.
And she just had a
huge smile on her face
because she knew that was
Lance and he was just a beast.
And sometimes, I think--
you didn't use too many,
but he would grab me
and shake me and--
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
There was one thing
that we didn't use where
he smelled a fart on set.
And he got mad.
And there's just a
take of him looking
at Emile, pretty convinced
that Emile farted.
And he's yelling very
deadly serious, who farted?
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah.
PAUL RUDD: He was terrifying.
I remember sitting next to him
and kind of out of nowhere he
goes, you know the
problem with kids today?
No grit.
And I was like, I know.
I have none.
I never felt less gritty
around anybody than Lance.
MATT SINGER: That
sounds like it could
be a line from like the next
"Anchorman" or something.
I could hear that
coming out of the voice
of one of the characters
or something, maybe.
Well, that's great.
Do we have any questions from
the Googlers in the audience?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So first of all,
I actually lived in Austin,
moved here pretty recently.
And on Cinco de Mayo,
I was next to you guys
eating at Curra's Grill.
So it's good to see you again.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
That's pretty amazing.
PAUL RUDD: How was your dinner?
AUDIENCE: It was awesome.
PAUL RUDD: What did
we have that night?
It's nice to see you, too.
MATT SINGER: They have
bananas in the rice,
if that recalls anything.
But anyway--
DAVID GORDON GREEN: I
remember you vividly.
AUDIENCE: I didn't
bother you guys.
It looked like you
had a good time.
But it's good to be here now.
Anyway, I was wondering
about the title.
Is "Prince Avalanche" the title
of the Icelandic film and that
was just a nod to loyalty?
Or why did we keep the
"avalanche" portion
when we were clearly in Austin?
MATT SINGER: Not in
avalanche country?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MATT SINGER: The title?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: I just
think it's a really cool title.
The Icelandic film was
called "Either Way."
You should all hunt
it down and find it
because it's a good movie.
"Prince Avalanche"
was a title I woke up
with after a strange dream.
And in my dream, I had a dream
that it was a cool title.
And then I woke up and it
really was a cool title.
So it was in the same
creative melting pot of time
that this project
was coming together.
And it seemed like a good idea.
EMILE HIRSCH: But with
the "avalanche" part,
would you say in France
they don't like it
because it's too
close to snowboarding?
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Yeah, they thought
it would be about snowboarding.
So they've changed the French
title to "Prince of Texas."
MATT SINGER: Not a
terrible title, I suppose.
It's not Alvin and
Lance together?
They kind of sound--
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Alvin and Lance?
MATT SINGER: Yeah, Alvin, Lance.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Put them together?
MATT SINGER: That's
what I thought.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
If his name was Lanch?
MATT SINGER: Lanch.
I don't know.
It's close.
It's kind of close.
PAUL RUDD: And it's Avil.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Avil and Lanch.
That would have been amazing.
MATT SINGER:
Admittedly, it would
have worked better if
those were their names.
PAUL RUDD: And instead
of "Bad Connection,"
we just listen to a
lot of Prince songs.
That sucked.
That was terrible.
I'm so sorry, Google.
God, I should have to
switch my browser for that.
MATT SINGER: Another
question right here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hey, guys.
How's it going?
Thanks a lot for coming
and showing us the movie.
Really appreciate it.
I actually had a question,
just a general question,
regarding the
improvisational nature
of a lot of the
scenes that happened.
I know, David, you're pretty
experienced with regarding
"Pineapple Express" and Paul
with Judd Apatow movies,
things like that.
Seems like there's a
lot of deleted scenes
with a lot of just
improv that's happening.
I was curious for the scene
with Emile, the, I guess,
disappointed weekend
where you actually
start crying in the middle?
How much of that was just you
off the cuff rolling with it?
Or was that scripted?
How did that whole
scene play out?
EMILE HIRSCH: That
scene was actually
almost completely scripted,
I think almost to the word.
I don't know.
That was just a
really long scene.
And I wasn't really just
going off the cuff or anything
on that one.
I mean, there were
some scenes where
there was elements of
improv, but never too much.
I mean, most of the dialogue
was in the script, I feel.
Surprise, surprise.
MATT SINGER: Is that
accurate, most of the dialogue
was in the script?
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
There's a good bit.
I honestly don't know because
I haven't read the script since
before we made the film.
I don't find scripts
particularly sacred or that
interesting.
I think if actors respond to
it, and it works for them,
and it feels believable when
we're rolling, then great.
If not, we'll throw it away.
We'll come up with
something new.
I mean, there's
plenty of sequences
that were designed out
of just the moment,
particularly when Emile's
out of town and Paul's
wandering around.
All that stuff was just
whimsical thoughts that we had,
a list of a few agendas.
And then we filmed things.
So the camera did its own
version of improvisation.
But I don't hold any
dialogue super close to me
as being super valuable
other than what feels honest.
MATT SINGER: Questions
from the crowd?
Oh, someone is-- It's a race.
Go!
Who will win?
AUDIENCE: I won.
MATT SINGER: You won.
Go ahead.
Congratulations.
Your reward is you
get to ask a question.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Well, first of all,
the movie's beautiful.
So I just want to say that.
I love the scene where you
guys are in the road right
after you've met
the truck driver.
And all of the trees
are super vertical.
And the lines are on the road.
So nicely done.
And now I'm going to
apologize because I
have a question for Paul.
First of all, congrats on the
anniversary of "Clueless."
It was a super important
piece of my childhood.
And I think I could quote
at least 75% of the movie.
I read somewhere
that you auditioned
for a lot of the major
male roles in the movie.
And I'm curious to hear
if you weren't going
to be Josh, who would
you have chosen to be?
And how do you think
your career might
have been different as a result
of being a different character?
MATT SINGER: Great question.
PAUL RUDD: That is, yeah.
MATT SINGER: Excellent question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
"Clueless."
PAUL RUDD: It is.
When I read that script
and I went in to audition
and I met Amy
Heckerling, I think
my initial audition
was for Josh.
But I thought, oh,
there was characters
I'd never seen before in movies.
And I remember
thinking Christian
was a great character.
And I think that
was the first one.
I thought, wow, a really cool
gay character in a teen movie.
I hadn't seen that.
I'd like to audition for that.
And I really wanted to
audition for-- I thought
it would be a great
character would
be the one that
Donald Faison played.
But I didn't realize
that he was black.
Yeah, I thought it was like a
white guy trying to be black.
Another thing I can't do.
And then I auditioned for Elton,
which was Jeremy Sisto's part.
And then finally, Amy
Heckerling said, well,
would you read for Josh?
And I said, yes, absolutely.
And so I auditioned for
that part and then--
AUDIENCE: The rest is history.
AUDIENCE: Here you are.
PAUL RUDD: And I'm just
still a little upset
I didn't get Miss Geist.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PAUL RUDD: Thank you.
MATT SINGER: Thank you.
Was there a question over here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is thing working?
I didn't prepare quite
so specific a question.
Anyway, I was wondering
if you guys could
talk about how Explosions in the
Sky got involved in this movie,
and how their music influenced
the tone of your editing
and how it all came together?
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Good question.
Explosions in the Sky, for
those of you who don't know,
is a wonderful band,
Austin-based band.
They collaborated with my
longtime composer David Wingo
to put the score of
the movie together.
We've been talking
for a long time.
They've done songs for two
of my films previously.
So we've had that relationship.
We go way back.
And a lot of us live in
the same neighborhood.
And so actually the whole
reason I went to the park
in the first place is the
drummer from Explosions,
Chris Hrasky, told me about it.
And he said, you got to
go check this park out.
I remember, we were
watching the Superbowl
and just talking
about cool shit to do.
And he's like, go make
a move in this park.
So that happened.
And then once it started
fleshing itself out,
we just started
talking about making
a bigger partnership
of the movie.
And it was really cool and
a very unusual experience
in that the musicians would come
to set, spent time hanging out,
got to know the
actors, got to know
the environment and
the tones, and started
going home and writing themes.
And so we had an
idea of where we
would go in the editing room.
Typically, in the
editing room, we'll
grab a score, some
songs from other movies,
and edit to them as a
temporary foundation
for where we want to go.
The problem with that is half
the time you use a movie score
and then you just have
to hire a composer
and say, kind of rip this off
because we really like it,
but make it your own
so we don't get sued.
So there's a lot of
those kind of problems
you have in editing.
Where here it was
really just a luxury
to be able to walk
down the street
and go over to Munaf's house.
And he's working on
this thing over here.
And the guys, the
musicians, will go over
at the end of the day
to David Wingo's house.
And we'll bring our
friend Mike Tully
to come beatbox for a track,
or a clarinet player comes in.
And so we could mess around with
some of their signature sound
and expand that a little bit.
And then walk over
to the editing room
and spend a little
time in there.
So it was all very much like
a high school class project.
It was very casual and laid
back and strangely efficient
that way.
There wasn't a whole lot of
back and forth and note sessions
and this and that because
we're engineering it together.
I mean, it was probably a
four, five week post-production
period, which is hardly time to
get a rough cut in most movies.
And we were done with
the score and done
with the cutting of
the film because they
were done simultaneously.
PAUL RUDD: Awesome.
That's so cool.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
And the soundtrack's
actually coming out on the 6th.
So if anybody liked the
music, then go check that out.
It was really cool.
The other day, I don't
know that you know this.
There's two dudes dressed
up like you guys painting
a mural in Brooklyn
for the album.
PAUL RUDD: No.
MATT SINGER: They
specifically dressed like?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: We sent
the costumes, the helmets.
They had the overalls.
And they were out
over on Bedford,
I think, out in Brooklyn.
EMILE HIRSCH: Did anyone
know what they were doing?
[INAUDIBLE].
MATT SINGER: Probably
no one thought
that was strange at all
in that part of Brooklyn.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Just some weird Mario
and Luigi just chilling
and painting on the side.
PAUL RUDD: Painting a mural.
MATT SINGER: Did you give
them the mustache, too?
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
I didn't see them.
I saw a couple snapshots.
I'll show you some pictures,
some weird ones, too.
MATT SINGER: Was the
mustache your choice?
Was it David's choice?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Yours, yeah.
PAUL RUDD: I think
it was mine, yeah.
MATT SINGER: Why did you feel
so strongly about the mustache?
PAUL RUDD: Because
it's set in 1988,
but it wasn't like
"The Wedding Singer."
It wasn't like a
movie that was like,
oh, we're going
to really lampoon
'80s fashion or anything.
It wasn't that at all.
But I wanted to
have something that
was like a little different.
And I remember I want to have
kind of Sally Jesse Raphael
glasses.
I thought the
combination of those
and a mustache and
kind of like short hair
but then a little
curlier on top seems--
I think I knew a guy
that had that look
and was friends with my parents
or something around that time.
And I thought that takes
it out of hipster, too,
because that was a concern.
EMILE HIRSCH: Redefines hipster.
PAUL RUDD: I don't know
if it redefines hipster.
And it also seemed to go
along with the rugged nature
that this character
thinks he has.
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Somebody I reference
a lot is summer camp counselors
from this very Christian camp
that I went to as a kid.
And there's always this guy
with a guitar, singing songs
with his shirt off
and his mustache.
PAUL RUDD: The L-Bar-C Ranch?
EMILE HIRSCH: Or
the guy that when
he talks to you to try to be
cool with the other students,
flips his chair around
and leans on the back--
DAVID GORDON GREEN:
Sits on it backwards?
Yeah.
EMILE HIRSCH: --and
puts his hat backwards.
MATT SINGER: But you
do in the movie, right?
Don't you have that move?
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Yeah,
he does something like that.
PAUL RUDD: I do.
I do turn around.
I go over to listen
to his story.
I flip the chair.
And that chair, by the way,
was made for two-year-olds.
It was such a small
part, another thing
that was just like-- There's
so many little things that
would just make us laugh.
It's like, why don't
we just be sitting
on a really small chair?
EMILE HIRSCH: Yeah,
and you remember
the day that we
did the scene where
Alvin's talking
about what he does?
He reads, paints,
sews, and he has
a lot of prescription
medication?
PAUL RUDD: Right.
EMILE HIRSCH: That scene we
could not keep a straight face.
PAUL RUDD: Well, it was also
because I took care of my pet
before it was killed.
And there was like no
explanation beyond that.
Just like, I had a pet.
It was killed.
And I just say it and
move on to the next thing.
That just really
struck me as funny.
And I still laugh at that.
But yeah, oh well.
MATT SINGER: I think we're
running out of time here.
If there was any
one last question?
Anybody?
We'll end with the striking
it funny, then, I guess.
Guys, thank you so
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID GORDON GREEN: Thank
you, guys, for coming.
PAUL RUDD: Thank you.
EMILE HIRSCH: Thank you.
MATT SINGER: Thank
you, everybody.
Thanks a lot.